on va retrouver notre pain c'est parrain
de l'émission c'est gad elmaleh qui est
avec nous pour cette dernière
aujourd'hui et gad elmaleh et devant une
porte qui va devoir trouver un invité
qui s'est caché chez lui
gad gad est ce qui m'attend gad ce que
là je vois que la porte je vois pas
gadrat voilà les gars allez vous rentrer
c'est une personne qui habite ici gad
oui comment il a raison une personne ne
peut pas une personne ne peut pas
habiter ici je vous jure garde que c'est
vraiment chez quelqu'un qui s'est caché
chez lui c'est vraiment le domicile d'un
d'une célébrité je vous jure que c'est
vrai j'habite vraiment ici essayez de
trouver de qui il s'agit chez vous sur
twitter qui est la célébrité hashtag
célébrités vous nous dites à votre avis
c'est qu'ils aient gad gars tu vas
devoir chercher quelqu'un qui sait
cacher c'est une vraie maison et c'est
la vraie maison d'une célébrité je vous
le dis wigan gadet vous cherchez elle
est comme en syrie oui vous êtes
embrassera vous êtes en angoisse je je
je crois pas que c'est la cuisine qua
non je crois que c'est la cuisine du
célébrités non là c'est pas la cuisine
c'est la cuisine ça oui si sa cuisine
une célébrité je vous jure que c'est
vrai gars je vous jure et ouaga quoi
vous le trouver il s'est caché quelque
part
non c'est non à la pistache et l'a hélas
pas plus que jésus la cad je vous jure
qui a vraiment quelqu'un qui s'est caché
chez lui
allez-y essayer de trouver qui est cette
célébrité qui s'est caché chez elle on
est vraiment chez quelqu'un regarder
mais vraiment je sais quoi gad 4e
brigade gad
mais ben on est chez jésus
god date c'est vraiment ces quelques
ajouts jury des vrais gars juico je vous
sens très angoissée c'est une vraie
maison garde j'ai une race rare quoi
vous êtes vous êtes vous avez
l'angoissent la célébrité c'est caché
ouais je vais vous donner un indice gad
la célébrité n'est pas tout seul
ouais gars dans la cheminée peut-être
dans la cheminée
il ya moïse norme doit la survie des
gardes peut-être qu'à l'aller la
regarder elle s'est cachée chez elle
c'est le cache-cache célébrités non y'a
pas le mime fait la caution galles gad
je vous le dis la célébrité et kachi non
pas là il ya vraiment quelqu'un qui
s'est caché chez lui sous la table gad
vous avez deux minutes pour la retrouver
maintenant deux minutes pour retrouver
cette célébrité
allez-y gars tu peux aller partout hein
ah ouais allez-y faites nous visiter ah
ouais quand même
allez-y il ya des portes en bois en fait
hein mais c'est un bon jour où il a
passé un donjon diouf a alors ah ah ah
je le sens bien là je le sens bien
gad vous avez trouvé ou pas
havas est très flippant six mois c'est
vrai vous voulez partir yade
gad gad et chez une célébrité qui s'est
caché
est-ce que vous avez une idée de la
célébrité vous ici autour de la taille
vous avez vous tous une ied et sans idée
sans garde ouais je pense qu'elle est
dans le sous-sol alésia chant tu veux
dire allez les gars dwi gad sava gad
vous inquiétez pas on est là faites
attention ne pas tomber inquiétez pas
c'est rien on va essayer de trouver la
célébrité garde est ce que vous avez une
idée de kyo de chez qui on est mais non
mais alors là aucune idée syrie je vous
jure c'est un truc de fou quoi parce que
c'est quand même
c'est ce que quelqu'un abertis idée
bissextile déjà quelqu'un habite ici
ghada les égales bd s'en aller at une
minute pour trouver la célébrité qui
s'est caché chez elle c'est à dire que
la célébrité ça fait [ __ ] depuis la
début de la soirée qu'elle est caché
elle est décédée dans un placard wii
garde il est très angoissé par la maison
c'est aller arrière
la gamme alors ah oui je le sens bien là
ramona
je trouvais ml doutez pas une seconde
elle jamais pensé que c'était nous c'est
bon galy sony céline brigade jamais
écoute moi bien je l'avais dit en
rentrant et 6 célébrités ne peut pas
habiter ici les deux mais heureux et
tish sa musique
allez
non
would you do bad garde mon chéri tu vas
venir tu vois pas quoi faire le tube
tout nouveau titre hommage sur scène on
va faire une belle soirée mousse et si
les modes dallavalle venir maintenir à
gattaca est énorme
voilà
ces deux génies cdg dia les adorait les
cowboys
c'est pas mais ils sont choqués y a que
ça qui te donne celle d'obama ils sont
cachés depuis une heure
non mais jure elles sont cachées prévu
une heure et demie